[MUSIC PLAYING]
NETO: Hey, I'm Neto.
JESSICA: Hi, I'm Jessica.
NETO: And we're here again
for the second episode
of "Behind the Action," right?
JESSICA: Mhm, yay!
NETO: And the last episode,
we created our first action,
right?
JESSICA: Mhm.
NETO: And it's working, yet?
JESSICA: Oh yeah, it's working.
And we can even try
it out on our home.
NETO: We'll give it a try.
JESSICA: Let's do it.
Hey, Google, talk to
Lucky Number Calculator.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: OK,
getting the test version
of Lucky Number Calculator.
[CHIMES]
Hello, what is your
favorite color?
JESSICA: I really like purple.
GOOGLE ASSISTANT: Your
lucky number is 210.
JESSICA: Ooh.
NETO: Amazing.
[LAUGHS]
This is so great.
But you see, in the beginning,
I heard a "test version?"
JESSICA: Yeah.
So this means that this is not
actually available to everybody
in the world just yet.
NETO: Oh?
JESSICA: This is only
available to our account
that we have that's on
this particular mini.
NETO: OK.
So on this episode,
we're going to guide you
through how we
get this published
to the real world,
so the what do you
call, the directory, right?
JESSICA: Yeah.
That way, everyone
has access to it.
So anyone could say
that phrase, and they
could play with this action.
NETO: We can also show
here, if you want,
for example, the
directory information.
So we can go to
assistant.google.com/explore.
And you're going to see, for
example, a lot of actions here.
This is like the catalog for
all the actions available.
So after you publish your
action, it will appear here.
JESSICA: Totally,
it'll be there.
Then that way you could share
that link out to other people
and be able to go, hey, try
out the action I just made it.
NETO: Exactly.
And if you check one of
these actions, for example,
you're going to see the ratings,
a lot of things for the Google
Express.
So can see ways to
activate this action,
what the available device that's
compatible with this action.
And also, reviews and
also, some rating numbers.
This is good.
So we can try.
And then, we want you to
get your action to this one.
So we go back to our Home.
Remember when we
said it's your Home?
JESSICA: Exactly.
Our Home, we're going to
go back to our Actions
on Google console.
NETO: What we are
seeing here, Jessica?
JESSICA: We're on
the Overview page.
And ideally, you want to
have it where you already
have the invocation done, and
then all the functionality
that you want.
And that was through our
actions using Dialogue Flow.
So we've got those
two things done.
We've tested it out
in the simulator.
And what's really nice is the
Nav bar pretty much tells us
the next thing is deployment.
So let's go under there,
under Directory Information.
NETO: Remember when
I showed you the name
and the number of devices
compatible and the other stuff?
This is entered all through this
Directory Information, right?
JESSICA: Exactly.
NETO: Because under Directory
Information, it's here.
So please.
JESSICA: Yeah,
let's open this up.
It looks like here we
add two different types
of descriptions.
We need a short description
and then a longer description
of the action itself.
NETO: And the other information
here is the sample invocations.
And here is important.
Because you're going
to teach your user how
you can invoke
your action itself.
Here can include, for
example, Talk To in the name,
or Ask To--
a set of ways that the person
can invoke your action,
ask your action.
And if you have something
called deep implicit invocation,
you can use here.
We did not cover this
on our last episode.
But it means that you can use
simple-- remember when you say,
my favorite color?
Imagine you have another one
where the three phrases is,
for example, book a ride.
You could see, call, ask the
name of the action to book
a ride.
And then what happened is,
these will be directly delivered
to the action, instead of
going for the welcome intent.
So if you see something
like that on other actions,
it's about the
in-place invocation.
But don't care about this
right now, don't worry.
We're going to go up.
And then some images,
why do we need images?
This is for voice.
JESSICA: Totally,
this is for voice.
But that's where the
directory that we had,
that we showed
earlier, this is what's
going to be shown on there.
So I'm going to just scroll
down just a little bit.
That way we can see.
There's a larger
image, and then there's
the shorter, or
the smaller image.
Larger image is for
the actual directory.
NETO: Yeah, let's
show here, I think.
JESSICA: Yeah.
NETO: So you can open here.
This is the icon, for example.
And if we hit back here,
this is the larger image,
you'll see here.
So this is the larger image.
And the other one is
more the icon for this.
JESSICA: Yeah, exactly.
And then after that is
all about the developer.
All about us.
NETO: Yes.
So here you must enter
your email information,
so someone can contact
you to report something.
Even to Google contact you,
if it's something necessary.
And also, the display name.
You can put your full name.
You can put your company name.
You don't need to have all the
same names for all the actions.
Each actions you can
use a different--
if you would like different
products of their own name,
or you are a third-party
developer that
is developing for someone,
you can use here no problem.
JESSICA: And then the
last thing on this part
is all about the
privacy and consent.
This is really important.
Every action needs to
have a privacy policy.
And that needs to
contain information
about what you're doing with
the user's information, or data.
This is really important for us.
NETO: Really important.
JESSICA: Because we want
to respect our users.
NETO: And remember, when
it comes to your action,
you have all the
responsibility on what
you are doing with this data.
So this is important to you.
Explain to your user
what you're doing.
And we have many regulations
in many different countries.
So what you provide here
is, for example, it's
a way that you can
use a Google Doc,
that you can create a link,
and share this link here,
in the privacy policy.
And this privacy policy,
user can access anytime.
But if you want to use your own
website, there is no problem,
so just put here the link.
And remember that we are
not providing any sample.
What we have here is just
a template for the file
so it can know how
to share the file.
The content's your
responsibility.
There are many services
online, or talk to a lawyer.
It's very important.
Don't-- don't let this--
can I say, don't ignore this.
JESSICA: No.
NETO: And also, this is
reviewed by our team.
JESSICA: Exactly.
If you do not have it, if
you just put a dummy link,
we do check it.
It's not too bad.
I would Google it.
There's, like Neto said,
tons of different services
that could support you.
And lawyers are
always helpful if you
want to go into legal things.
NETO: Yeah.
And also, if you want to put
some kind of terms of service.
For example, you
are accepting this.
We are reading, or we're
storing this information
to provide you a customized
solution, home mortgage
calculator, I don't know,
something like that.
Remember to put the
terms of service.
Because there are
different things, right?
Terms of services is how you
are providing the service.
And the privacy policy's
about the privacy of the user.
But the second one, the terms
of service, it's optional.
So you don't need
to enter right now.
There is some
additional information.
JESSICA: Yeah,
let's click on that.
Let's go down.
There we go.
So category.
NETO: Yeah, this is nice.
JESSICA: This is
where we could choose
where this should
live, in regards
to what type of category,
in the directory.
I feel like ours is like a game.
So it'd make sense to
put this in the game--
NETO: Games in Fun?
JESSICA: Yeah.
So that would make sense.
So it depends on your action.
Whatever you think it
matches with that category,
just choose that.
NETO: Yeah.
And now, one very cool
thing about for families.
If you think your action
is suitable for families,
it's family-friendly,
please, no bad words.
No content that's-- right?
JESSICA: Right.
Of course they wouldn't.
NETO: But why it
should be a good idea
to develop for a family?
Because we are
curating this content.
And we have a specific
session for a family.
So if someone wants
to play something
with the kids, their kids,
they can use this session.
It's nice.
In our case, for example,
we are able to say
that's for a family.
But you're not
sure, don't do it,
but read the documentation also.
And if you are
referring or saying
something about alcohol
and tobacco, also, please,
you should be
explicit about this.
JESSICA: Yeah, let us know.
That way we could let our
users know about that too.
NETO: Yeah.
And there is testing
instructions, right?
JESSICA: Mhm.
NETO: For example, imagine
when the person is reviewing
your action, needs maybe
to do a specific logging
or run a specific query
to show how it's working.
Because all the actions
are validated and tested
by a human.
It's not only automated tests.
So if you want to say something
for the person that's testing,
then, please, right here.
There are some other
interesting topics.
JESSICA: Yeah.
So there's Transactions,
just asking
whether you're using the
Transactions API, and then
the Digital Purchasing API.
So if you're using those,
you, of course, click Yes.
NETO: And there's a mic policy.
Because sometimes, for
example, you maybe leave the--
JESSICA: Microphone on.
NETO: --microphone open.
But if you're not prompting for
answer, you must click here.
Because then the user must say,
yeah, it's kind of hearing me.
But remember, the timeout's
like, eight seconds.
At some point, if there's
no way to put the mic,
it's closed within the action.
It's closed as well.
So it's not hearing the
ambient all the time.
JESSICA: Yeah.
I would say, this is my policy.
Leaving it open is
very special cases.
NETO: Yeah.
JESSICA: Generally, most
actions don't need that.
NETO: Yeah, exactly.
JESSICA: So we
filled all this out.
NETO: Yes.
When I fill it out,
what should I do next?
JESSICA: I think we should
just do surface capabilities.
Let's tell Google what options.
NETO: Oh, yes, Discard.
We are not saving right now.
But remember, you need
to save all the time.
What is this screen
all about, Jessica?
JESSICA: This is all about
telling Google on what devices
does this action work with?
There are times where
someone might build
an action that needs a visual.
And so you have
to mark that down,
that it requires
a screen output.
And that way we're not
servicing those actions
on just audio-only devices,
like Homes and Minis.
NETO: Yeah, for example,
if you are building--
I can give an example of
something I was playing with,
a chess voice, so we can play
chess, saying the movements.
But you need to see the board.
JESSICA: Yeah, you do.
NETO: So in this case,
I would click here
that it requires a screen.
JESSICA: That makes sense.
NETO: And also, it's
not OK to play in a car.
So Android Auto, I wouldn't
publish for Android Auto.
I don't want to cause any
accident, car crashes.
So like Jessica said,
we can choose whatever
is better for your action.
JESSICA: Yeah.
So once we get that done,
the next thing is release.
Here there's a couple
of options we could do.
NETO: And this is very cool.
Because imagine
you're working here,
and we want to test with
more people, but not only
our account.
But it's not yet
ready for publish.
JESSICA: Everybody.
NETO: Yes.
There's two stages we can use.
One is the alpha.
What is the alpha?
JESSICA: So Alpha lets
you test with 20 people.
You grab their
emails, and you put it
into this Alpha Testers List.
And you deploy just to those.
Those 20 people have
access to your action,
to be able to play
around with it.
NETO: Nice.
And then when it's
almost ready, and you
want to expand the
number of people testing,
there is a Beta.
JESSICA: So with Alpha,
there is no review process.
It goes out.
It's available to
those 20 people.
Beta, you do get the review.
NETO: Exactly.
So it will go through
all the regular process,
but won't be available
for everyone.
And when it's done, you can
just promote to the production.
Or if you want you go
straight for production,
you are totally confident,
no problem this button
Submit for Production
will be enabled.
You just click.
Then you will receive
an email saying, hey,
your action is under review.
So you can wait some.
In general, we say
takes up to two weeks.
But sometimes it's getting
earlier, a little bit.
No, don't say I said that, OK?
JESSICA: Don't
quote him on that.
NETO: Don't tell them that.
But yes, wait.
Because it's like I
said, it's a real review.
It's not something
just automated,
because we take
this very serious.
So the kind of content,
the interactions,
and everything else.
JESSICA: Exactly.
And if there is an issue,
it will be reported back
to you why it
didn't get deployed,
it didn't pass the review.
And generally, it usually
links out to our Docs
too, to help support you to be
able to solve that problem too.
So it's a really nice tool.
Or a really nice service.
NETO: Yeah, so we can easily
fix and meet again if you want.
So it'll then be ready--
how can I say?
It would be really
straightforward to have
your action available
for everyone.
Then you can say
hey, it's available.
Please test your devices.
JESSICA: Yeah, mhm.
NETO: Go ahead and share it to
your friends, your customers,
whatever.
JESSICA: Yeah, because
once it's on the directory,
you could even use that
link, and then send that out
through your social
media campaign,
through an email campaign,
and letting people
know this thing's alive,
it works, it's out there.
NETO: Yeah.
And for example, if you
have a specific feature
on the website, or
on your Android app,
or in a mobile app that
you want to call out,
OK, you can try this for voice.
You can try this by voice.
Yeah, say, put the link,
and "train" the person.
Say to the user,
hey, user, say this.
It's a great way to
complement your experience
across devices, services.
It's amazing.
JESSICA: Exactly.
NETO: Well, this was
kind of a short episode.
But we hope you enjoyed,
because now you are
ready to go with your action.
So I imagine you had some time
to play more and make something
more advanced than
our lucky number.
Then you can now go
and publish online.
So please, give us your Like.
It's important to
us to know that you
are enjoying the content.
Subscribe to our channel, to
the Google Developers Channel.
And please, give
us your comments.
Right, Jessica?
JESSICA: Oh, definitely.
We want to hear your feedback.
Especially for next episodes.
That way, let us know
something that you're
interested in for future videos.
We could build that out
and be able to deliver
the content that you want.
NETO: Yeah.
Thanks for watching.
Stay tuned for the next
"Behind the Action."
Bye.
JESSICA: Bye.